Fox News national security strategist
and former deputy assistant to the
president Sebastian Gorka Fox News
contributor investigative reporter Sarah
Carter Fox News legal analyst Greg
Jarrett
Sarah I want to go back to where we were
last night this was back in March of
26th of last year that you literally
first said wait a minute we've
discovered that a FISA warrant was
obtained to spy on you no then-candidate
Trump and maybe another warrant you and
John Solomon breaking the story not to
explain to my friends that are so
impatient why it's taking so long
because it's been literally a layer of
onion a day because we've had to have
the evidence and each piece of this
puzzle is another piece of evidence that
we can deliver to the American people
into Congress and when Congress took
over and when the Department of Justice
took over their unraveling they're
moving forward with with the
investigations that we weren't privy to
because we couldn't access the
classified information it is so
important to understand that had we not
looked into this had Hillary Clinton won
we would have never known that this was
happening and this is exactly what they
expected to happen this is why they got
so lazy this is why we see those text
messages between Peter's struck and Lisa
Paige and now Shawn this is really
interesting you know before I got here I
was contacted by law enforcement
officials both former FBI and current
and they were saying to me get the text
messages from Angie McCabe get his text
messages find out what was going on
there because there's a lot more where
Lisa struck and where where Peter struck
at least a page left off there's a lot
more to be seen there and you know once
again this is one piece of the puzzle at
a time and this is what we've got to do
to uncover the truth and I think that
the American people will be just as
shocked as Congress and I think they're
going to get those answers very shortly
Greg Gerald let's go to the legal side
of this you have been examining every
aspect of it tell us where we are and do
you agree with my calls for the firings
anybody you disagree with oh absolutely
officials should be impeached which
means they can't hold another government
position but I suspect this Intel
document is going to reveal multiple
felonies by high-ranking officials that
the FBI and the Department of Justice
there's a federal felony statute it's
called deprivation of rights under color
of law and it says that a government
official cannot use their position of
power to deprive somebody of their
constitutional rights here
it's the constitutional right to privacy
is upheld by the Supreme Court so if the
FBI and the DOJ goes into a federal
judge using a fake false document to
obtain a warrant to spy that's a
violation it's a felony it's 10 years
behind bars people ought to be
prosecuted for that Eddie is there
anyone you disagree with that should be
fired and do you agree that the Special
Counsel Robert Muller needs to be
disbanded because it was all done on
false pretenses and it seems it was all
done illegally well one of the
congressmen who saw this four-page Intel
document said yesterday people ought to
be fired and he named names and one of
them in addition to Bruce or as rod
Rosenstein who's the acting Attorney
General in the Muller investigation he's
Muller's boss he's overseen if he goes
Muller should go and so should his
investigation dr. korkor you were in the
White House for a big period at this
time I've got to imagine this becomes
very distracting in the fact that it's
all predicated on something that is
false erroneous and that we've had no
evidence for in a year probably
frustrating to you well it was but the
president told me one day in the Oval
just the two of us that they will find
nothing because there is no Russian
collusion so the president must be
commended for being completely hands-off
with regards to all these absurd
allegations and investigations but I
have to repeat and emphasize something
you said in your monologue Sean just
before I came to the studio I spoke to
my sources as well the
Moe is the tip of the iceberg that
refers to DOJ and FBI malfeasance and
felonious activity weaponizing
intelligence against US citizens but
that goes much higher greeting
oh absolutely sherry and remember Shawn
it was about the FISA it was about five
to seven oh two abusing that system and
remember they collect everything this is
not just about foreigners there's a
collection of all Americans so every
call that's made overseas every email
everything I want to know how many
people within the Trump campaign and
within the Trump administration they
were actually how many people have
surveilled and unmasked and leaped upon
it so I want to say this all of you have
been amazing thank you for your hard
work in the last year we have another
year of hard work ahead